buckle up game of thrones fans this
bizarre break from canon has literally
changed the course of westerosi history
keep watching to find out how
considering the abysmal fan response
that the final season of game of thrones
received it's not surprising that many
viewers were skeptical of house of the
dragon the latest show to come from
george r martin's a song of ice and fire
indeed the series was already dealing
with some ugly backlash before its
premiere as the casting of lord corliss
valarian was met with a slew of racist
messages across social media in addition
to this hateful backlash many other fans
claimed that they refused to watch the
show on principle alone citing the
unsatisfying conclusion to game of
thrones and the different route that
series took to the books narrative
fortunately one major difference between
the two shows is that house of the
dragon is based on a fully completed
story which is chronicled throughout
martin's fire and blood as such you
might assume that house of the dragon
will have a much easier time sticking to
the cannon of a song of fice and fire
which ought to appease some of the more
vocal skeptics of the series
unfortunately for some however it
appears that the show has already broken
from the book series canon in its very
first episode episode one of house of
the dragon features the scene in which a
young rhaenyra targaryen and alison
hightower read a book together deep
within the red keeps godswood i want to
fly with you and dragon back see the
great wonders across the narrow scene
eat only cake
behind them is a white weirwood tree
with a face carved into it which is
traditionally worshiped by followers of
the old gods the inclusion of this
particular weirwood not only breaks the
canon of the book series but of game of
thrones itself in the books the king's
landing god's wood does not have a
weirwood but an old oak wrapped in smoke
berry vines the false weirwood appears
during eddard stark's stay in king's
landing when he and his daughters pray
to the tree and give their thanks for
bran stark's miraculous survival we also
see the red keeps god's wood in the
fourth season of game of thrones episode
two swords when sansa stark visits it
and conspires with cerdanto's hollard in
both appearances there is no mention or
sight of the massive weirwood that
appears in house of the dragon making
its inclusion in the prequel series a
bizarre break from the established canon
of the show and the books although some
fans might chalk this up to the simple
fact that house of the dragon takes
place more than a century before the
events of game of thrones it's worth
remembering that we already know what
happened to the weirwoods in southern
westeros until this point it's been
implied that if king's landing ever had
a weirwood it would have been destroyed
by the andals when they first came to
westeros george r martin's the world of
ice and fire explains that when the
andals first invaded westeros they burnt
down most of the indigenous people's
god's woods in order to make room for
the faith of the seven the destruction
of these godswoods was more concentrated
in the south than it was in the north
though the text does clarify that many
of the more important southern castles
were allowed to keep their god's woods
as a gesture of good faith although some
might take this to mean that the red
keeps weirwood was spared and might have
actually existed during the time of
house of the dragon king's landing as a
whole wasn't even built until the
invasion of aegon the conqueror several
thousand years after the andals invaded
so why would the andals spare this
specific tree in a godswood for a castle
that was not yet built we don't know the
truth is that the inclusion of the
weirwood tree and house of the dragon
amends the history we thought we knew
about king's landing and establishes
that at one point in time there was a
weirwood growing deep within the red
keep that said it will be interesting to
see what becomes of the tree as the
series goes on as its absence in game of
thrones suggests we should get some
answers
eventually